good afternoon everyone i'm lee goldman
i'm the dean of the faculties of health
sciences in medicine and all of us in
the Health Sciences schools are
delighted to be part of today's a world
leaders forum I always recognize that no
one comes to these just dying to hear
the introductory remarks of the first
person who comes to the podium so I'm
going to be uncharacteristically brief
welcome you all here on behalf of
Columbia and Columbia University Medical
Center and say how delighted I am that
we have such spectacular people here
today as part of this program I'll be
introducing dr. Freid the Dean but just
allowed to have ray Suarez from a PBS
newshour Tony falchi head of the niaid
whose guidance and really shepherding of
research and advances and aids have
transformed the epidemic Eric Goosby the
global aids coordinator who's mostly
responsible for the PEPFAR program
Michelle Sidibe executive director of
you an aids and the coordinator of the
global response the AIDS epidemic as
well as our own waffles solder a
director of I cap and a professor at the
Melbourne School of Public Health and
also a professor of medicine in the
medical school there isn't anybody who
hasn't been touched by AIDS directly
indirectly repetitively one of my most
transformative experiences was when I
joined dr. al-sadr for a trip to four
different countries in sub-saharan
Africa and saw a first-hand not only the
way we and others deliver care but also
the patients who sometimes would walk
for days to get that care the global
response to HIV has been truly
extraordinary but in reality this
epidemic has required the extraordinary
I'm just delighted today that we have
some people here who are a part of that
extraordinary response this point I'll
turn the program over to
Dean Linda free to the mailman School of
Public Health
well good afternoon it's my great honor
to be a participant in today's a very
important event I think and to join in
welcoming you all here to Columbia
University's world leaders forum one of
the roles of great organizations and I
think today's panelists represent great
organizations is to ask the right
questions and today's program which
asked both visionary and I hope and
think transformative questions is on a
future without hiv/aids dream or reality
it features a prominent and
distinguished panel of leaders who dr.
Goldman already mentioned who are in the
position collaboratively as well as
individually to Shepherd a dream into a
reality as dramatic scientific advances
in the treatment of hiv/aids fuel our
hopes for the promise of a cure and
deaths from hiv/aids are on the decline
we progress with very heavy hearts
knowing that worldwide over 30 million
people have died from the disease and
some two and a half million new
infections occur each year icap led by
dr. raphael satter and anchored at the
mailman school public health is
co-sponsoring today's world leaders
forum to ask this transformative
question of world leaders dr. al-sadr
herself is a global leader in hiv/aids
services research and education to a
transformative goal I Kappa supported
and led work at more than 1200 sites
across 21 countries around the world and
has provided among many other exemplary
accomplishments more than a treatment
for HIV AIDS for more than 1 million
people around the world it is now my
distinct pleasure to introduce today's
moderator ray Suarez senior
correspondent for PBS news hour mr.
Suarez is a Brooklyn New York
native so we're doubly triply proud and
the parent of a columbia college student
who has covered local national and
international stories over the course of
a clearly illustrious career of some 30
years he is author authored numerous
books including his most recent work the
politics of faith in america garnering a
Latino Book Award in 2007 mr. Suarez
hosts the monthly foreign affairs
program America abroad heard on public
radio international stations and around
the world on NPR worldwide please join
me in welcoming mr. ray Suarez who will
introduce our distinguished panel
thanks very much to Columbia for
bringing me home to New York and
bringing me to this campus where I get
to visit occasionally but my money
visits every couple of months so I it is
a joy but a tempered joy to be able to
participate in a conference that even
dares to dream about a future without
aids my career as a reporter has really
lined up with the AIDS epidemic
worldwide as a young reporter i sat in
clinics in New York and Los Angeles with
men my age who were sure they were dying
very soon and most of them were exactly
right where i sat in a clinic in
Humboldt Park in Chicago on the west
side that was built just to answer the
needs of children born HIV infected to
treat them mostly at that time until
they died a very premature and tragic
death but I guess if you do this long
enough you get to tell good news stories
along with the bad news stories so being
on a farm in rural Mozambique with a
woman hoeing her fields who talked about
weighing 75 pounds at one point but now
she's back to producing on her land and
expects to live a really long life or a
woman in Morocco who thinks she's one of
the first known AIDS cases in Morocco
now middle-aged who was able to live
long past the life that she expected
would be cut very short 20 years ago
when she heard that I was from the
United States one of the first questions
she asked me was do you know wathah al
Sadr
I had to admit that that yes I did so we
have a tremendous amount of intellectual
firepower on today's panel and if I read
you their CVS we would be here for the
rest of the morning we take one question
and then go to lunch so what I'm going
to do is just give you a quick sketch of
of each of these a big big name pioneers
in the world of AIDS research and in
fighting the disease both in the United
States and around the world Anthony foul
Chi has been the director of NIAID since
1984 and in that same way lines up with
the worldwide AIDS epidemic his career
has been carried on along with the march
of HIV and AIDS around the world not
only does he deliver really hard hitting
thorough teaching on how the world can
respond and what the United States
should do but he's also been a standout
researcher in the early days of
unlocking the secrets that the HIV virus
held earlier in his career dr. Eric
Goosby was long a leader in the fight
against AIDS before he became the u.s.
global aids coordinator for President
Obama as a leader of pangaea global aids
foundation from 2001 to 2009 but now
with the rank of ambassador I guess it
makes you even smarter as you go around
the world and tell people what they
ought to know well wafaa al-sadr is your
Columbia homegirl here but as at but I
cap is dug in around the world really
doing daily heroic work in both in
understanding the disease and treating
it around the world and Michel Sidibe
was long in the fight before he became
the executive director of UN
aids working regionally and in the UN
aids administration before becoming the
the director over all of the program I
want to welcome you all here in the
beautiful low library but also people
who are watching this panel live
streamed over Columbia's pipes and over
the online news hour around the world as
well so you lucky people who get to sit
in this gorgeous rotunda get one view
but also we're joined by people who are
unknown to us and and watching our work
thousands of miles away so welcome to
you all let's get started the theme of
the recent international aids conference
was turning the tide and knowing how
cautious public health people are I know
that that even choosing that title must
have seemed like an audacious act or one
that could finally be imagined but would
have been audacious before when we
talked about turning the tide dr.
al-sadr what do we mean at ground level
where people live and work and interact
with each other I think it is true that
the choice of the word of the theme of
turning aside and actually the seam was
turning the fight together and it's very
important to remember that work together
and there was immense discussions about
what it means on the ground and what has
been accomplished in what are we going
to accomplish there was a realization in
thinking about this theme that there are
so many tools that are available now
scientific pieces of evidence
interventions that we've discovered that
can save the lives of people as well as
methods that could prevent the spread of
HIV and that if we really brought
together these interventions and
knowledge we have both in terms of
scientific knowledge but also a depth of
knowledge of how to take this evidence
into action
I've how to work with people on the
ground to translate the knowledge into
programs and to scale them up to achieve
the impact on populations it is through
that kind of the confluence of the
knowledge and the action and the
partnerships that there are there was a
realization there is a realization that
we have a chance now to turn the tide on
on AIDS if we are we can come together
bring the resources bring our knowledge
together bring the partnerships together
and work together so we can actually
turn the tide and transform this
epidemic in our lifetime at the
population level and I think it was this
this grasp by many people were involved
in the planning of the conference real
grasp of the importance of the moment
and that this moment was a
transformative moment and we should
grasp this moment and mobilize around it
so that we can line up what we need to
essentially accomplish with the people
on the ground who are facing new
infections every day with HIV or her
becoming ill with HIV how can we do all
of this together and really have that
impact on the ground whether it be right
here in New York or in Washington DC or
in the fields and Mozambique that this
was what needed to happen why dr. Sidibe
is is this a transformative moment there
are still thousands of new infections a
day around the world and yet I've never
seen this kind of optimism before about
being able to really turn down the trend
line of new infections I think you use
the water optimism and i would like to
link to what you use before talking
about the dreams i think a leader
without the dream because we have a
future leadership it is a bureaucrat is
someone who will not be able to use this
transformative moment to go to scale and
when I was talking about zero new
infection zero discrimination zero deaf
people told me we shall you're naive how
you as a leader of the wall on 8 you can
talk about 000
I can tell you today the Saints and I'm
lucky to have a photo with me yeah the
sounds science is showing that is
possible for the first time I can say in
the story of Public Health we have been
able to increase so quickly the number
of people were in need of treatment in a
few years time just a 10 years back in
Africa less than 50,000 people on
treatment today we are talking about the
6.4 million no one was telling us that
our prevention program with work were
just talking about what Thailand Uganda
for years as a good example today we
have 56 countries in the world who have
been able to stabilize the epidemic even
to decrease significantly the number of
new infection we have been almost broken
the I can say is broken at the
trajectory of this infection today so it
is a period it is a momentum being
creative which can really help us to say
oh we are turning the tide is we are
turning the type and I'm positive about
that and I believe that we need to
continue to invest because we are seeing
is showing return on our investment the
results are being produced well dr.
Goosby that the CD we mentioned
investment and 6.4 million people on
ARVs in Africa half of them are being
paid for by the American taxpayer what's
the shape of our investment can the
United States carry so much of this
burden by itself off into the future and
are we getting the kind of help the kind
of partners we want and need if as we go
forward well i think that the United
States commitment to sustaining and
increasing resources to support both
prevention and treatment efforts
the global effort are solid both
Secretary Clinton and President Obama
have made policy level statements about
their commitment to an aids-free
generation I think Michelle's comments
about the number of new infections going
down the prevention interventions the
condom testing systems that have to come
together to meet the populations at
highest risk to get tested and move them
into staging and treatment if they're
positive the additional drop that's seen
with pmtct male circumcision and then
the addition of treatment on top of that
we are approaching a moment where the
number of new infections that are
occurring on the planet will be exceeded
by the number of people who are going on
to treatment and that crossing of the
lines will precipitously draw incidence
curves much steeper slopes and we are
able to say that we are going to pretty
much be at a point where we are rapidly
dropping the number of new infections
because of the potentiation which that
will benefit from the treatment
prevention contribution all of that to
say that the commitment is real but we
realize that we will not do this just
with the United States resources but
that the United States resources
remained remain foundational we
understand that relationship the
challenge is as Wafaa says is to bring
the diversification of different
resources that fund this effort
understand what they are what's the
country's contribution and that's been a
struggle to define that explicitly and
then to look at mainly PEPFAR and Global
Fund as the big motors of resources
other foundations and bilateral programs
contributing as well too
create a diversification of the
portfolio of resources in each country
so the likelihood that if one drops off
or increases or decreases it minimizes
the impact and we'll be able to sustain
these programs the united states with
PEPFAR came out of the chute with an
emergency response to stop kind of the
death and dying as we move from 50,000
people in sub-saharan Africa on
antiretroviral drugs as Michelle said
now were at the 6.5 million about
seventy percent of that being in
sub-saharan Africa we are at a point
where those resources now are much more
explicitly understood so we can hold
each other accountable to keep that
sustain that and to increase it I think
that the movement in that emergency
response that move people from a
predominantly impatient dominated
response the first time we were seeing
patients was when they presented with
their opportunistic infections largely
to what is now largely an outpatient
response picking people up earlier in
this in their disease before they
develop a hospitalization requiring
admission has transformed the medical
delivery systems they can now see other
diseases but it's also put us in a
position where we can take stock and now
look at what each country is going to
need and have a explicit plan that moves
forward so it's transformative on all
those levels and really is reflective of
I think a sea change yeah I want just to
add to what Eric said data because your
question was a pertinent one yes alone
can do it no I think we are today in the
period where the world is changing ten
years ago if you look at what was the
cover page of economies Africa was
mansion as up less continent and just a
three months ago if you look at the same
newspaper
our page Africa is rising we have a
growth rate of six seven percent what we
are trying to do today is to bring the
debate of share responsibility making
sure that yes alone will not pay but the
countries will start also looking on
their own budget you cannot put someone
on treatment for example for 30 years
and thinking that will come only from
abroad resource which will maintain them
will come only from abroad we are seeing
change happening yesterday we had a very
good meeting with Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton with head of states of
Africa discussing and we are seeing
Namibia paying almost a sixty percent of
their own budget South Africa 1.9
billion dollars now on hiv/aids programs
so this change positive change is
important we are seeing Wanda
introducing health insurance scheme
which we are not existing so I think
it's important to just mention that the
debate is shifting is not anymore one
part of the world as a morning and the
other part of a world as a problem I
think the paradigm is more complex today
people or coming around the table using
aids as an entry point to open a new
debate debate around governance system
is not just ate global health in general
dr. franchi you've heard your colleagues
talk about treatment and the importance
of getting on treatment recently when I
was in Johannesburg Central Hospital one
of the great heroes in the fight against
aids harried obviously having a very bad
day said to me we've been trying
education for 20 years we still have
hundreds of thousands of new infections
and we're never going to medicate our
way out of this epidemic she might be
wrong given what the other panelists
have said if you lower the viral load in
such a way that even
people who are not being responsible
become less infectious maybe we can
medicate our way out of this epidemic
well I think what you're putting a wedge
in here ray is the pitting treatment
against prevention is the subtext the
bit okay there has to be a little
tension on the conversation so so let me
just take a minute or so and get into
that because that's really a very
important issue that we all face it is
true behavioral change is very very
difficult particularly when it comes in
the background of sexuality and poverty
and many other things in people's lives
which really impact greatly their
ability to quote change their behavior
but if you look at the combination of
Prevention's that we have some of which
are biologically related like
circumcision or mother to child
transmission prevention or pre exposure
prophylaxis together with the things
like condom use etc that we already have
in play a combination of prevention
modalities that clearly have the
capability the tools to turn around the
trajectory of the pandemic if you
superimpose upon that something that we
just recently became aware of from a
scientific standpoint we suspected it by
cohort studies that when you really
penetrate a community and treat people
get the viral load down the actual
incidence of infection in that community
goes down because we know from
heterosexual couples that are discord
and one infected one not mother to child
transmission the probability of
transmitting to another person is
directly related to the viral load so if
you get the viral load low below
detectable level there's an
extraordinarily low chance now if you
say well if that's the case why don't we
just treat everybody and therefore it'll
be just treat our way out of the
pandemic that would be a mistake you
have to put them both together you have
to have the combination prevention
modalities both biologically and
behaviorally related and
superimposed upon that the very very
powerful tool of what we're calling
treatment as prevention and it's really
a beautiful phenomenon because there
were and I was joking with you Ray but
there was attention early on and we all
know that because we were there about
resources for prevention or resources
for treatment now it's one package that
really synergizes with itself so that's
really one of the reasons why we're all
excited about the fact that we do see
the light at the end of the tunnel and
and people ask me well how come you you
all said that and we will all at the
meeting you said that you could possibly
have an aids-free generation and you
didn't say that ten years ago well
because we didn't have all the tools and
we didn't yet prove that the tools that
were efficacious in a clinical trial
actually became effective in the field
and we know that now the only barrier
between us and the goal line is that we
know we can put an end to AIDS the
question is will we put an end to AIDS
and that will be the kinds of
commitments that we're talking about at
the country level at the PEPFAR Global
Fund other organizations but the
ownership of this problem by the part of
the companies that I don't feel overly
confident in the sense of well okay we
can do what it's over walk away from it
but I think if we apply ourselves this
statement of turning the tide to gether
is not just blowing smoke I think it's a
reality I think what's also quite unique
to HIV epidemic is that while
historically they've been a lot of
discovery scientific discoveries that
unfortunately often sit on the shelf or
go in the dustbin somewhere I think
what's been unique about the HIV
response and the scientific discovery is
how fast they move from discovery faced
actually to action how fast we take a
result of a study and then are able to
take it and apply it and not just
implemented in one place but scale it up
for millions of people around the world
and I think that's quite unique about
the HIV epidemic so I'm optimistic not
just by the tools we know already that
we've discovered whether they be
preventional male circumcision or prep
which is pre exposure prophylaxis that's
when people who are negative can take
medicines and stay negative is that the
ability to take these discoveries and
actually take them to action is very
unique to the HIV epidemic which makes
us all very optimistic that we can
package these interventions together to
achieve what we want to achieve I think
another aspect of the HIV response that
I also think is quite unique is the
transformation that has happened as the
health systems and you can have a
wonderful vaccine discovered tomorrow
for HIV for example but if you don't
have a way of bringing that to the
country and distributing it and giving
it to people and people accepting and
coming to receive it you'll never have
the outcome you want you never have that
benefit of a discovery but I think
what's been unique about HIV is because
of the scale-up of treatment in
particular and also a prevention if
systems are now in place systems are in
place that can generate demand for some
of these interventions they're people
who are well trained their facilities
that have been renovated and are poised
to expand and see more people and
provide these combinations of
interventions so the changes in the
health system the changes in the society
itself people much more engaged in
trying to control the epidemic in their
communities I think in addition to the
scientific discoveries really offer an
opportunity to do something quite
different I was reading recently a
report by some what dr. bill Fahy some
of you may know who was the architect or
one of the architects of the there's the
campaign that led to the eradication of
smallpox in the 1970s and what was
interesting and he wrote this and I'm
paraphrasing this somewhat is he said
that the response or the eradication of
smallpox was based on us on a strategy
that was rooted in science it was based
on knowing about surveillance knowing
that we have a vaccine making a vaccine
that you didn't need to refrigerate
getting the vaccine out there but while
it was a strategy based on science
was also the tactics of that campaign
were based in culture and that's very
important to keep in mind that we need
the scientific evidence but we need to
route our tactics in community factors
and these other psychosocial societal
factors are so critical and unique to
the HIV epidemic and I think when we
bring the science that strategy the
scientific strategies as well as depth
of knowledge of these tactical ways that
we need to enable these things to happen
in partnership with these communities I
think then we have a chance to succeed
dr. Goosby I'm glad dr. al-sadr brought
up improving medical systems because the
United States has put a lot more
emphasis on health care infrastructure
in developing countries than simply more
than simply supplying medicine supplying
gloves supplying syringes you want to
make sure it's better administered and
you you've gotten a little static over
that to talk about the changes in
emphasis in the United States policy
well I think you've said it nicely it's
it would be tragic if we infused these
resources into these medical delivery
systems and did not look for every
opportunity to expand capacity to
nurture the ability to identify enter
and retain patience and care it's rooted
in the acknowledgement that the people
that PEPFAR was focused on the
hiv-positive individual has needs it's a
complicated progressive chronic disease
that evolved into really having to have
a medical delivery system that can take
care of the totality of that patients
needs which include hypertension
diabetes and coronary artery disease so
the nurse the doctor the laboratory the
patient information system the
procurement distribution system that
makes it all happen are all essential
ingredients to any medical delivery
system for any disease we have embraced
that as opposed
shunned from it and have found that with
very little in the way of moving money
differently all boats who have risen in
a profound way and I think that it
started with the debulking of the
impatient dominated response so for any
of you who were in sub-saharan Africa or
the United States in the early 80s but
certainly sub-saharan Africa until
recently you had congested multiple
people on wards with hiv-related illness
that has changed in almost every country
were in the drop in incidents and the
earlier identification and pick up of
individuals the coatroom ox's all the
initiation of antiretrovirals the
understanding of co-infection with TB
and getting better at all of those
things has dropped inpatient
considerably but the human resources and
the kind of infrastructure in the
medical delivery system have expanded
with it and we have I think not been
good at describing that additional
benefit but it is there I might say that
it's too modest to say but this is a
result of a phenomenal amount of
creativity and and commitment on it Eric
spot because when he was making these
transformations there was a lot of
skepticism that this one would be done
and he forged on so every way to go but
on one level it sets up a virtuous cycle
where more people get treated for other
things that are not AIDS which is great
and they are more likely to know their
HIV status which is great but once they
know it they go on ARVs and you've now
forged a relationship with them that's
going to last for decades and some
countries have developed pipeline
problems where a clinic that used to
give you your month's supply of
antiretrovirals and you take it and come
back a month later and get your next
month's now can only give you a week at
a time
which means you've got to come to the
clinic four times as often spend very
very rare coins on bus fare to get there
find childcare in many cases leave
precious jobs to take a half a day's
journey to the nearby dispensary it's a
wonderful problem to have we're keeping
more people alive but it also shows that
the world is hardly a wash in ARVs if
we've got half the people who need
treatment on it and even those people
can't always get what they need when
they need it what what strides are we
making doctor see today on drug supply
and the pipeline I will come back to
what just thought she said treatment as
prevention is a very important because
for me is a game changer it is changing
completely our way to deal with this
epidemic we will need to address
certainly the delivery system less Wi-Fi
said and also in the developing
countries to scale up we will have to
certainly rethink completely awara the
way we deal with the workforce is not
possible to waiter to hava the best
trend from Harvard or Columbia to be
able to reach the millions of people
were in need of this treatment today we
need to tap on non-conventional capacity
we need to certainly reinforce the
interface between service provider and
community making sure that we we will
have you were talking about distribution
system and others to rethink completely
the treatment approach we have today the
pills we have is too complicated we need
a simplified the pill which can be given
to people maybe for two months and one
pillar maybe a day why not one pill a
month we need completely to use visa a
GameChanger to change completely the
paradigm of dealing with a public health
treatment 80s and on three point is an
opportunity to help us to do that and I
believe that is what we need to start up
bringing in the debate a pharmaceutical
firm need to come around the table to
start thinking which type of pill we can
give and we have to also know that some
part of our cities are revealing that
forty percent of the people were
stopping treatment is due to lack of
proper nutrition drugs could be toxic
are we producing drugs today which or
could be used on areas where people or
eating one said a day all those issues
are certainly very important to be
addressed dr. falchi what changes about
a disease when it shifts from a death
sentence to a manageable chronic
condition do people worry about it less
do people fear it less and are there
some important things that the AIDS
community has to keep in mind as it
talks about prevention oh absolutely
that's one of the things that we face
not only with HIV but in other diseases
but it's particularly important in HIV
that you become almost a victim of your
success when you get a situation where
everyone was desperate and and I can
clearly remember those days in the early
80s where virtually every patient that
we all saw died it was the darkest years
of my medical career and the darkest
years of the community particularly here
in New York and in San Francisco and
other places that the motivation for
preventing something that was a death
sentence where you saw a substantial
proportion of your colleagues
dramatically ill it hospice type
situations that's a tremendous
motivation
the problem we need to address now and
that's the reason why the combination
prevention you could never ever let up
on that is that when you see now the ads
even and I always get struck by those
ads of the antiretroviral you see
somebody who's buff healthy rock
climbing you know use use a triplet it
it's true you can be that way but that
gives the image that this isn't such a
bad problem so we can be a little bit
careless and there are some clear
situations where because of the
complacency we have a problem with
motivating people and prevention
modalities we have to stay on top of
that in a very very aggressive way and
even and this is important to rate
because if I wouldn't say if but when we
achieve that aids-free generation and we
put a quote end to AIDS you have to
sustain that what we don't want to see
is the curve of the inflection of the
incidents to go down people on treatment
and then when we see that we have things
relatively under control we've learned
from syphilis we've learned from
tuberculosis there's control and there's
maintenance of control so prevention
becomes even more acutely important once
you get things under control because you
don't want to bounce back in the other
directions that was a very good question
that you posed dr. al-sadr I've had
people in clinics in the field talk
about how the idea that you can live and
live a healthy life is a really
important tool for them to get people in
to get them aware of their status and
get them on treatment but those same
buff people who are in the in the
medicine ads may not make you scared of
contracting HIV or scared enough to make
sure you don't contract HIV well that's
interesting actually when we look at the
evidence and
you know what does the evidence tell us
over the past five years for example I
what's interesting is with the scale-up
of treatment which substantially train
change the landscape health facilities
communities I mean communities were the
biggest business as you all know is
making coffins and selling coffins that
are just that's gone completely so
there's been this transformation that's
happened were people living better
looking healthier and so on at the same
time we're also seeing a decrease in the
numbers of new infections so I want to
temper the fear that people have that
somehow with expansion of treatment some
people with us I used to hear this
actually when we started our very first
programs of trying to demonstrate that
it's feasible to do treatment of people
with HIV in sub-saharan Africa and
people said exactly the same thing is
what people are going to take those
pills they're not going to do they're
not going to use condoms it's going to
get worse and worse and worse than be
resistant virus and the end of the world
kind of scenario we're not seeing that
what we're seeing is that somehow with
the scale-up of treatment with all the
benefits to the individuals themselves
who are HIV infected and to their
children in their communities at the
same time we're seeing a decrease in
numbers of new infections so it tells me
that it's much more complex then this
idea of this inhibition that people they
don't see people sick in their community
they're not going to behave chevra less
risky behaviors I think there's a
massive decrease in their infectiousness
through treatment but also who knows
there also are as well potentially
decreases in risky behaviors as well
there are noted and that's been seen in
several studies when people are on these
new intervention you can actually see a
decrease in risky behavior rather than
an increase in risky behaviors so the
data are mixed but the population level
data are encouraging that with
increasing treatment we actually seeing
a decrease in new infections and that's
in multiple countries and in sub-saharan
Africa we haven't seen this in the
united states yet which is quite
interesting i always try to bring back
the u.s. epidemic to the discussion
where we have it we've had probably
same number of new infections annually
for the past decade or so and that's
despite at least officially access to
treatment pretty much access to
treatment so we do have challenges in
this country that get at trying to find
everybody who's infected about a quarter
of people who have HIV don't know it in
the US so those are behaviors that we
need to change people need to know the
status feel comfortable knowing your
status and then the issue of this whole
cascade of then getting into care
getting on treatment staying on
treatment so that we start reaping the
benefits of these interventions as well
as we have a huge other challenge which
is of course dealing with some of our
most disenfranchised populations in this
country who feel that they're not cared
for they don't have access to the
services the services are not attuned to
their needs so we have some real
challenges to overcome in this country
in order to start seeing the same thing
as we're seeing elsewhere the decrease
in new infections in the United States
that we're now remarkably noting in
sub-saharan Africa and other countries
around the world well dr. Goosby what's
different about the profile of the
disease in the United States when you
compare it with the rest of the world
well the United States is burdened by
concentrated epidemics as Wafaa said
you've got 1.2 million people infected
the numbers around forty seven thousand
per year new infections has been
remarkably stable way back into the
early 90s 93-94 its predominant in men
who have sex with men gay white men gay
men of color women African excuse me
African American women Hispanic women
and then you have a really tragic mantle
alignment of delivery system access with
injection drug using populations to
create safe spaces so these populations
that are participating in highest risk
can reveal themselves to medical
institutions be identified and entered
safely without fear of being arrested or
being revealed to the authorities quote
has to be repeated and established with
each new generation that comes forward
it's not a one-time hit like Tony was
saying you need to be repetitive with
this but you need to be aggressive
around it and we as a society have not
embraced the complexity of drug
addiction of the the difficulty that gay
people have in integrating into our
society is still very high in many areas
of our country and the best responses in
terms of needle exchange and drug
treatment having you know from good
people very strong feelings about the
appropriateness of paying for those
types of interventions even though the
science is very clear that they are very
effective and when applied you drop
incidents so I think that we have to be
aggressive at looking at where the high
risk behavior is and going backward to
identify how that population is
identified entered and retained in care
neighborhood by neighborhood it's not
one epidemic its multiple epidemics in a
city in one city and you've got to as a
system of public health be nimble and
acknowledge that you have to have
multiple access points and protect them
recently the head of AIDS Alabama told
me that it's one thing to be HIV
positive in New York or San Francisco or
DC it's another thing to be HIV positive
in Alabama where communities are smaller
where treatment is less widely available
and fear of being known as an HIV person
positive person
is much much higher because of local
cultural norms is there a coastal
heartland and urban-rural split in the
experience of HIV and AIDS in the United
States I would say generally yes there
is both coasts have more sophisticated
responses that have been hard and coming
they've been longer working at it
they're more mature as you move into
rural settings even in states like New
York or California which you would think
would have a degree of sophistication
and maturity with their responses you
still see that people afraid to go to
the clinic the day that HIV is being
seen in the clinic because their pickup
truck will be seen in front of it having
in rural settings ray you're right to
say they went to school with maybe the
receptionist and immediately they feel
vulnerable by revealing themselves even
though there's an air of confidentiality
around it small communities really
everybody does eventually know
everything you could extend it's
different being infected with HIV in New
York or San Francisco versus rural
Alabama you could extend that to be it's
it's different being at risk for
infection in those places because the
capability of counseling the openness of
being able to accept a person who's gay
took to go into a clinic to talk to
their friends to ask to be tested that
even gets before you're infected so it's
really a double negative whammy
unfortunately recently like address
anything that you make me think of you
know the the one wonderful thing about
the medical profession is is that nobody
we don't have to make any judgment about
the behavior it's not our job to make a
judgment we're not a faith-based
organization or a religious belief
system we have to remember that our main
role
is to respond to the person in front of
us embrace them and in every instance
make decisions that are in their best
interest that kind of theme needs to
roll out both in rural areas in the
United States in some pockets within
cities in the United States but in many
places in sub-saharan Africa and
throughout the world that kind of Creed
of behavior is not as prominent in our
colleagues who are in the health
profession in many of the countries were
in and is another area that we need to
address well perhaps you wouldn't use
the word judge but you do want to make
them stop doing things that make
themselves sick and threaten other
people with with their own deaths you do
I think that taking the position that
you educate them so they understand the
risk to themselves and to others is a
central piece of the relationship and
the exchange it needs to be repetitive
that trust needs to be built but i think
that when a medical delivery system
start to say that this behavior pattern
and this population is acceptable to us
and we respond to that versus this
population you've taken a step on a very
slippery slope i mean i think it's also
important to keep in mind is that we we
tend to think of risk for HIV and
personal behaviors something you did
that's wrong or that's risky there's
there's substantial evidence from the
United States for example that when you
look at black MSM for example and you
look at they are extremely high risk of
getting HIV infected but actually when
you examined their behaviors the risk
behaviors they tend to have less risky
behaviors than non black MSM so it's
it's complicated and we tend to always
go and say you did something this must
be something you're doing that's wrong
that got you HIV which is getting at
what Erich is saying it's much more
complicated
it's kind of the mill year in which
these individuals reside it's their
partners it's the amount of testing that
happens in the community the number of
people around individuals who know their
status and their behavior but we have
evidence now that demonstrates that it's
not just individual behaviors that it's
often these what people call structural
issues or societal issues of partner
behaviors and I think it's this the
complexity of the epidemic is so
interesting to to appreciate and it is
quite different based on where you're at
I'm often asked when I'm in Africa in
sub-saharan Africa to sell things must
be so much easier in the United States
and when I'm here working in Harlem I
hear the opposite you know so and their
lessons learned i think the epidemic
here is quite different is a
concentrated epidemic with very discreet
hotspots we do know where transmission
is happening we know in whom
transmission is happening and i think in
the u.s. we have a really a golden
opportunity to turn the tide in our
country as well by using this evidence
and focusing on that populations
engaging them but focusing on the why
are they frisked and trying to stop that
rather than simply saying people you
know stop doing this and stop doing that
because i think often that's not that's
part of the answer but that's not the
complete answer and there are lots of
lessons learned from subsidiary's say
that lessons from Africa that applied to
Harlem and lessons from Harlem they fly
to Africa and we should be trying to
really learn from the response the
global response which has been amazingly
effective and take this still some of
the models of care some of the
engagements we've done with the
communities in sub-saharan Africa and
take those lessons learned and try to
think about how do we tailor them to
respond to something that's happening
right here not to see the bay if we look
at countries that have managed to turn
down the curve of new infections that
have made it a value a social value to
know your HIV status are there
similarities between Uganda and Botswana
and
and kwazulu-natal senegal places that
have taken their own national approach
but perhaps have some things in common
like taking the guilt taking the
judgment out of what is essentially a
medical assessment I will say that for
three to four common observation we can
see in different places first is that
young people stop to be just a passive
beneficiaries of our program and they
want to be utter of change I think that
is something very important because when
they are actor of change they become
capable law as generally to play this
interface with their peers and Alfred to
change completely our primary prevention
approach that's first so only I think I
saw progress happening when we managed
to foster the link between science and
social change I can just say that you
can have a best evidence for example
circumcision and it will not be used if
you don't foster the link between
science and social change from Uganda to
kwazulu-natal use gave a good example
when I met the king of kwazulu-natal and
I was trying to convince him to really
every introduced circumcisions it told
me you know the zulu king shaka stopped
the circumcision 200 years ago because
he was losing is a battle against the
English people and he was thinking that
the young people adolescent who could
help him to fight were circumcised and
we're not capable to joint is a fight
for three weeks so he just decided to
stop
incision people are saying no Zulu
culturally were not circumcised is not
true and he said for the survival of
Zulu nation is the same reason which is
pushing him now as a king to reintroduce
her concision the day the king of zulu
king decided to reintroduce a transition
it has been a shift completely in the
nature of our capacity to access to
people for going to scale with those
programs so the link between I think
evidence scientific evidence and social
change is very important because like
what I was saying sometimes we are
focusing on individual behavior when
it's mainly about practice is about what
is happening between the society is
about taboos how to remove them so that
is a certain other element I saw in most
of those places is when we have been
able to deal with conspiracy of silence
in most of those places one of the major
barrier was stigma discrimination when
we have been able to work with those
leaders to break the conspiracy of
silence to make people coming out to be
able to really identify themselves and
not to be afraid of being rejected
service was used so I want to say that
in many places the issues is not so much
just the evidence and the availability
of medical services is how we deal with
with this interface and that is critical
we have mics in the aisle to take your
questions all that I ask is that they
actually take the form of a question
your voice goes up at the end implying
that you're asking a question
and not making a speech about HIV and
AIDS I'm sure many of you are very
passionate and knowledgeable but please
ask our panelists a real live question
and while we get people to come up to
the mics one thing I had clinicians
recently telling me in DC on the
occasion of the world aids meeting there
was that they're struggling to get HIV
status to be like blood pressure your
cholesterol number just another health
metric if they could build down some of
the stigma build down some of the terror
of knowing it would go a long way toward
helping them put out the fire where they
live and where they practice what are
the barriers to that if everybody if
every doctor was told in DC or places
like it you know while you're doing this
do this other tests as well just add
this screen to the screens you're
already doing is it that hard dr. funky
no it's not I mean it could be done
originally the the exceptionalism that
we put two aides and an HIV test was
because of all of the negative
consequences that could fall upon
someone if they were found to be HIV
positive that's the first thing you know
insurances all the bad things that have
happened and in some respects
unfortunately still happen because of
the stigma also the associated now
inappropriate in 2012 linkage to saying
that if somebody gets an HIV test they
must be at risk and what is risk me risk
is the bad things that society
stigmatizes people against I think that
right now at least I mean I live in
Washington DC and we have a study
whopper and and mog group together with
the South Bronx to Sister Cities if you
want to call it that between Washington
and the Bronx that we're trying to get
over that that we get people you know
aggressively trying to get people tested
and one of the ways to do that ray
is exactly what you're quoting is to
make it part of the normal health care
delivery system you come in for a
glucose you come in for a hematocrit get
an HIV test and there will still be some
stigma associated with that but i think
the benefit for that would
overwhelmingly supersede that i do think
i'm an agreement and we're learning very
important lessons from the study that
the tony mentioned in the bronx and in
Washington I do think we have a ways to
go with health care workers and you know
they are part of the society and they
carry sometimes the same preconceived
ideas about what this means what HIV
means and what asking somebody to get
the test and they're themselves very
often uncomfortable we're talking about
HIV or getting the test or even asking
someone if they don't mind getting the
HIV test and I think that's going to
take we're doing a lot of work to try to
turn that around but it's routinized
this process and getting health care
systems but providers whether it's not
just doctors but the nurses to feel
comfortable with this the clerk in the
front of the clinic the person in the
emergency department yet everybody to
feel this comforter I think I have ways
to go even in this country and that's a
lesson that I think we can learn from
sub-saharan Africa where HIV has become
much more of a routinized tested it's
called opt out is that your people tell
you about the test and then they do the
test unless you say I don't want to get
it done so that there's some some of
these countries in sub-saharan Africa
are leading the way and trying to to get
where we want to get to in our own
country but I think it's a we have
always to go to get our providers at all
levels to embrace this as something
that's important to the health of of the
community and the health of their
patients if their answers have been so
thorough that it leaves you totally
question lyst I understand but there
must be yes first thank you all for
speaking to us it's I'm really great to
hear from all of you my question is for
dr. Goosby given that Congress has cut
the PEPFAR budget this year and the this
really vital program is
reauthorization in 2013 I was just
wondering what are your plans for PEPFAR
reauthorization and specifically if your
blueprint will include concrete
treatment targets we have been able to
get much better at using our resources
effectively when we came in in the Obama
administration there were 1.7 people on
treatment from PEPFAR we're now up to
4.5 we've had essentially flat funding
throughout that period and it's because
of our ability to be smarter and more
aggressive in moving to high-impact
interventions and shifting taking
advantage we've been the fruit of all of
the groundwork that occurred in early
PEPFAR to build medical delivery systems
that had to be put up that could see
only 30 people that same system without
any expansion of human resources or any
of the other elements that make a system
work can now see 300 people so it's not
magic what happened it was just the
convergence of those elements we will
continue to be efficient and get more
out of that as we move forward in
addition the Global Fund now has started
those same reform efforts we put a third
of the money into the Global Fund so we
will reap many we will reap that same
efficiency in the Global Fund the third
element is that we are now planning and
implementing together in 17 countries
with the Global Fund this will give us a
profound opportunity if I could say it
that way to be efficient Nandu pitov and
focus as we're doing on true capacity
expansion of community and civil society
as well as public sector service sites
so I think that we only are optimistic
for the
immediate future I think that the
arguments around reauthorization are
going to be little it is still very much
a bipartisan effort I've been relieved
at that because the new leadership that
came into Congress did not know didn't
have the same kind of collective
consciousness of what HIV and the
epidemic did had done they are people
who are younger are largely not
professional politicians and we're
coming in with a very specific cause
they really weren't planning to stay
they wanted to come in cut resources
that the government was spending and
that was the agenda so the interest in
kind of what your program was etcetera
was something we had to aggressively
insert into and everybody up on this
stage have played a role in informing
congressional leadership around the
importance of the interventions that did
start with President Bush and continued
with President Obama the commitment I
now know is strong bipartisan and if the
Congress does indeed engage and pass
things next year this probably has a
good chance of getting looked at if it
isn't if there is no reauthorization
that happens because Congress doesn't
deal with it we will continue as a
program have the same authorities it'll
go from year to year so it won't poof
even if it's not reauthorized so I
really want you to hear that yes sir
good afternoon panel my name is Arnold
ganzen an alumni board member of mailmen
my question it was only mentioned once
nutrition so my question is how
important is nutrition intervention a in
the treatment be to put for relapse
prevention maintenance specifically
protein intervention
well I could just say very quickly
nutrition is critical you cannot give
the antiretroviral medicines effectively
on stomachs that are not getting food
full preferably people don't tolerate it
well and you end up interrupting or
stopping therapy because the patient
doesn't tolerate it on almost a local
mucosal level so nutrition is critical
the immune reconstitution is blunted and
nutritionally depleted individuals we've
seen that really in children and adults
throughout the world India was the first
place we saw that and the recognition
that even small amounts of vitamin A and
trace elements really do potentiate the
immune reconstitution response so we see
it as a critical piece PEPFAR pays for a
lot of nutrition yes hi I was surprised
at first I want to say thank you for
your comments and your thoughtful
discussion I was surprised given the
rate of HIV both in this country and
abroad among adolescents and young
people under the age of 30 there was
very little mention outside mr. sidib
on the distinct prevention needs of
adolescents and young people and I'm
wondering if you all could address that
both domestically here in the US but
then also abroad whether through PEPFAR
or otherwise good question well
adolescents are different if if I could
answer that and they do require a
different approach to identify them as
well as retain them over time this city
and donna Federman's work has applied
globally and it's the same basic issues
that we see over and over again PEPFAR
is just getting to the point where we
realize we need to develop specific
strategies for the adolescents in the
populations we've already interfaced
with so we're catching up with that I
think also they've been some interesting
of care for adolescents and particularly
for those not just
identified when their adolescence but
those who are who are children with HIV
and our aging now into adolescence which
is they have other challenges they
didn't acquire HIV sexually but they
behavior sexually but they acquired it
through mother to child transmission
I've was just recently visiting the
program that I could supports with
PEPFAR support in Kenya for example and
so fantastic peer educator groups of
adolescence many of them with HIV
themselves who are have disclosed and
are now rallying together to shape
helped shape programs that are
particularly suited for adolescence not
just for caring a treatment but also for
prevention that's 90 days yes I think
it's very important question and I was
mentioning that today children and
particularly adolescent they don't want
to be considered as a passive
beneficiaries of our program they want
to be actor the world is changing
completely and we had a very good
experience I crud out aids and which was
the first time when i try to ask to my
stuff that i am tired to see a policy
and strategy which are develop in un aid
office for young people when we have
today it different means to communicate
with them why we don't crowd out aids
believe me 5000 to 6000 young people
adolescent connect themselves through
with new media mechanism communication
mechanism 70 countries and they came out
with their own policy and which has been
presented to our board as a young people
policy and you know what is coming out
of that first they are calling for
universal sexuality education they are
saying that you are completely missing
the point you will never have a
sexuality education today which is
tailored for mauritania and sexuality
education Tyler for us the world is a
flat communication is happening in
different way those young people are
communicating you need to start thinking
about how sexuality
education can become Universal to how
you are empowering young girls to be
able to negotiate their sexuality in
responsible manner that is so
fundamental to use the education system
to shift completely the paradigm term
what resources are you putting in all
the funding you have I'm asking for
example pepper Global Fund which
percentage of resources are going to
young people to empower them to make
them part of this change we are talking
about those are fundamental aspect which
are coming from this consultation which
is a very important shift in the
paradigm we are having a positive spin
off in the success that we've had and
I'm speaking purely from a research
standpoint about the resources that go
into pediatric HIV because back before
the dramatic results in the prevention
of mother-to-child transmission
essentially all of the resources that
we're research resources went into
preventing mother-to-child transmission
right now in this country and in some
developing world countries including
sub-saharan Africa the incidence of
mother-to-child transmission has gone
spectacularly low in fact I had I
brought up the point in my talking in
Washington this summer that the people
in the audience couldn't believe it that
in Washington DC which has the highest
prevalence of any city in the country
actually hasn't had a mother to child
transmission in that city since 2009
which is good news the reason I bring it
up is because now we can shift our
resources to looking at the adolescent
situation we've done such a very good
job in blocking mother to child
transmission here in the United States
and doing even better in the developing
world yes man my questions also about
resources and it's for any member of
this terrific panel part of turning the
tide it means maintaining millions of
people in dozens of countries on
antiretroviral treatment for decades
right and even if we
looking in the short term we've talked
about reauthorizing pepped are but
looking further down the road you've
alluded on the panel today to
diversifying resources diversifying
funding streams how do you see it
playing out how would this
diversification happen do whether the
prospects for reducing costs through
pharmaceutical and improvements along
the lines of what dr. C today was
talking about I would love to hear your
thoughts on that that's a question that
we could spend another whole seminar and
answering but but somebody do it briefly
eric said I did ya know Annie can I add
something I I do think that there's a
limit to efficiencies and sharing of I
mean I think that a lot has been done to
achieve efficiencies and to do more with
less and to expand the pie as much as
positive try to do better with what we
have however I think we'll be naive for
us to think that this is a long-term
investment and needs to be a long-term
investments by wealthy countries like
ours for many many years until we get to
the end of AIDS I mean I really think
this is a commitment as we've made other
commitments for other issues that the
many poor countries around the world are
facing and I think we should be prepared
that that will happen and needs to
happen rather than at the same time
we're trying to gain efficiencies and
bring that prices of drugs down and so
on but I do think this is a substantial
and should be conceived as a substantial
long-term commitment by hopefully by the
US government as well as other wealthy
countries around the world I think also
it has been underestimated the
investments that these countries in the
in the South that poor South have
actually invested in these programs from
day one it's there's this perception
somehow the Global Fund and that far
just the money that and magically all
the success has happened there's been a
tremendous investment by the countries
themselves it's their facilities it's
their workforce it's
their institutions that have been
investing the people and the graduates
and so on and I think we've enabled it
through the external assistance to to be
able to get to where we're getting but
they have substantially invested as well
and now we're trying to kind of put a
numbers to those investments and
increase those investments but i am not
naive enough to think that somehow over
the years that this responsibility for
tackling the epidemic of our generation
is going to be able to be fully the
burden will be fully carried by some of
the poorest countries in the world I
think that point is very important one I
remember saying in Washington data
ending AIDS is not free it is not
expensive it is priceless I said that
because is at the end is a life which
are in balance we are very happy to have
eight million people on treatment but we
have to remember like you said in 2020
will have 30 million people in need of
treatment and most of those people were
on treatment today during first line
treatment and we have been working very
well to reduce the price offers life
thanks to all the effort of people of
war Iran visa panel we reduced from
fifteen thousand dollars to eighty
dollars but we have to move again back
to second line third line and what we
will do I think that is very important
question secondly I we have to continue
to encourage countries had to be part of
the process of taking some part of the
burden I was just a saying that I
produced a reporter with a dependency
crisis eighty percent of a people 285
war on treatment or on treatment based
on drugs coming from India thanks to
India but if to tomorrow we have a
market failure because they want to move
out of this a production line to go to
another drugs and could be Java trees or
whatever what will happen to our
we have another language we need to
explore is 81 countries have been
increasing through our continuing
advocacy by 50% their own resources on a
treatment and AIDS of programs are
during the last 34 years we need to
continue with that one we need to make
sure that we have investment case
business plan for those countries to
make sure that this transition moving
from where we are to long-term thinking
will happen if not it will be in serious
problem we are the roadmap for 2015
having people on treatment Weaver thanks
to their work we are the guidelines for
early treatment we are the guidelines
for pregnant women wafaa and orders were
but is to all of that is a very good but
the risk you mention is critical 17
billion gap and this gap is killing do
you have a quick brief question in one
panelist good answer yeah it's for dr.
crotchy it's kind of round about the
research side of a possible HIV vaccine
or if it exists already but my question
is about how close it is to becoming
something similar to like the HPV
vaccine where you give to adolescents
and is it like the technology or the
stigma that's attached Oh having a
having to have the HIV vaccine or is it
some characteristic of the HIV the virus
that makes it a challenge to target and
if you had developed a vaccination would
you choose to go more the treatment
methods or the screening methods versus
vaccinating before as prevention would
that we had the opportunity to worry
about the policy that we would use if we
had a vaccine having said that the
answer specific to your question is that
unlike other infectious diseases where
when you develop a vaccine you tend to
try and mimic with the vaccine what the
natural infection does and the response
is it elicits because almost all
infections but even the deadly ones like
smallpox and
measles and polio and others that even
though a certain percentage of the
people die and there's a degree of
morbidity at the end of the day the body
ultimately makes an immune response that
totally rids the body of the virus and
gives you what is usually lifelong
protection unfortunately for us that's
absolutely not the case the body does
not respond immunologically in an
appropriate way to contain HIV which is
the reason why there are no spontaneous
cures of HIV so having said that what
I'm saying is that the challenge now is
really a scientific challenge not an
implementation challenge not a policy
challenge and it's it's good that you
brought that question up in the light of
what we were talking about tools that we
have that we just need to implement a
vaccine is a tool that we don't have yet
I believe we will have it because a
couple of years ago we had a
proof-of-concept trial that showed that
you can actually protect in a modestly
small number of people but you still
could protect with a vaccine that we
tried in Thailand several years ago so
it really is a scientific challenge once
we get it I think we can just vaccinate
at risk people and I wouldn't be
surprised by that time that we would be
vaccinating anybody like we do at
hepatitis B that's what I would like to
see if we had it it would be a hepatitis
B HPV type thing but my timekeeper let
me get facial and I guess I take this
last one or do I have to wrap it up okay
make it elegant and brief absolutely
thanks to the panel for this discussion
and my question actually follows up very
much on the last one I really appreciate
the discussion on a future without HIV
AIDS but for those of us who are living
with HIV there won't be a future unless
we have a cure and so I wonder how
important it is that we continue to fund
research for a cure recognizing what a
scientific challenge that is well it's a
very short but precise answer is that we
are very committed from a research
standpoint to find a cure it's a
daunting challenge because of the nature
of HIV and how it integrates itself
to the genome of a cell and you want to
be careful that you don't have a cure
that's worse than the treatment that we
have but indirect answer to your
question we have a substantial amount of
resources and commitment that we are not
only putting into a cure but that we're
increasing so if you look at the
relative priorities from a research
challenge the two important ones are
vaccine and a cure and as Michelle
mentioned long-acting drugs is another
one that we really need to do thank you
for your questions thank you for your
presence and the victories that are
being one in this battle are in no small
measure thanks to the efforts of the
people on this stage so please thank
them as well I will end up
let let me just and with my usual
advocacy by 2015 we can have a
generation free of HIV we need you in
this battle I think it will be the
beginning of the end of this epidemic we
have been launching a global plan and
today we have 22 countries were
mobilized with a pepper to make sure
that it could be possible waffa was the
science behind all of that and we of
course a 4g also and it will cost one
point I said $150 to stop the
transmission and if his baby is born
with HIV it will cost us minimum of
three hundred thousand dollars only to
treat so let us make sure that we don't
have babies born with HIV by 2015 thank
you very much
so on behalf of Columbia University I
cannot thank all of our speakers and
particularly our lead questioner today
for what has really exemplified for the
rest of us why leadership matters and
what 21st century leadership looks like
we started out by saying the asking of
transformative questions and the vision
of a better future is key to our
leadership linking science to social
change but what we've seen is the
demonstration of all the elements of
leaders in themselves and leaders of
institutions pulling together toward a
collective goal for many sectors with an
underpinning both of knowledge and a
commitment to science a commitment to
the core values that we share and a
commitment to bringing science into
impact thank you all so much
you